my name is Dale Martin I teach in the
Religious Studies department and I'm
serving this year as the acting chair of
the Terry lectures committee and I have
the pleasure of introducing our Terry
lectures for this year our series of
lectures and semester as well as our
speaker for the first time while I'm at
it everybody turn these off
just a reminder Phillip pitcher is the
John Dewey professor of philosophy in
the Department of Philosophy at Columbia
University this was not planned but it
is certainly a happy coincidence that
kitc are as the John Dewey professor is
giving the Terry lectures 80 years after
Dewey did so 1933 John Dewey gave the
Terry lectures here at Yale and in 34
the lectures were published by Yale
University Press as a common faith
Dewey's terry lectures advocated a
scientifically informed sort of theism
shorn of what he called supernatural
elements Dewey was though a Unitarian
and his view of religion and ethics was
sometimes called religious humanism it
has been said I'm not sure I agree with
this but it has been claimed that with
the death of John Dewey in 1952
religious humanism also died to be then
replaced by secular humanism so that is
perfect that now 80 years have to do his
lectures we have an advocate of secular
humanism as our terry lecturer philip
pitcher was born in london raised on the
south coast of england educated at
Cambridge and then at Princeton where
Thomas Kuhn was one of his teachers he
early on studied the philosophy of
mathematics and later philosophy of
biology and the sciences more generally
in 1982 he published abusing science
the case against creationism and his
work has continually circled back to the
relationship between science and
religion one of his well
works is his 2009 book living with
Darwin evolution design and the future
of faith in his most recently published
book the ethical project published in
2011 from which we may hear
reverberations in his lecture on
Thursday which is entitled ethics as a
human project in that book Kitchel
proposes that we think of ethical values
not as deriving from divine revelation
nor as the discoveries of human geniuses
but as having evolved over many years as
human beings attempted to discern better
ways of living with one another ethics
as empirical one might say he has
published at my last count 12 books and
seemingly countless articles and essays
pitcher was the first person to be
awarded the Prometheus prize from the
American Philosophical Association in
2006 his Terry lectures address several
issues related to secular humanism in
lectures this coming Thursday and
Tuesday and Thursday of next week he
will speak on ethics as a human project
mortality and meaning and depth and
depravity his lecture for today is
titled beyond doubt please help me
welcome Philip Karcher to Yale
well thank you very much for that
splendid introduction it's a pleasure to
be here and a great honor especially
since Dewey is not only the man for whom
my chair is named but also one of my
intellectual heroes and you may hear
some resonances of Dewey's original
tenant Terry lectures in what I'm going
to say so let me begin secular humanism
begins in doubt but doubt should be only
the beginning for anyone who is once
lived under the sway of religion the
rejection of religious commitment leaves
a vacuum demanding to be filled the
fully secular life cries out for
orientation it isn't achieved by bare
denial
however strident or caustic the denial
may be we live in a time when the most
prominent forms of viii is atheism seem
content to conclude their onslaught on
religious doctrines by singing hymns to
the glories of scientific understanding
and I think it's easy today to
sympathize with William James's pithy
characterization of the fervent atheist
he believes in no God and worships him
if it's to be lived and to be understood
as a fully rewarding way for us to live
secular humanism requires positive
elaboration a purely negative critique
arouses reactive doubt to the effect
that secularists have ignored pervasive
aspects of people's lives that the human
has entirely disappeared from view
clusters of comfortable intellectuals
may be satisfied by secular humanism but
people not primarily focused on the
search for knowledge or people more
exposed the vicissitudes of the world
will want substitutes for the guiding
ideas that they've had to give up my
main aim in these lectures is to explore
one possible way of articulating a
secular humanism and I'm going to try to
answer the
complained that it entails important
losses I'm going to try to show that
secular humanism can provide a
satisfying account of values that it
finds room for the meaning of human
lives that it can answer major
challenges posed by the fact of our
mortality and that it neither condemns
us to a shallow form of existence nor
overlooks the darkness of human nature
yet although my primary purpose is the
construction of a positive perspective
today I want to start with the reasons
for secularists skepticism secular
humanism begins after all with doubt
what kinds of doubt about religion of
course but to say that only provokes a
further question what exactly is
religion or what counts as a religion a
popular but in cautious answer
identifies religions with bodies of
doctrine about the existence and
characteristics of special kinds of
beings deities who deserve our worship
and service because of their impressive
attributes one straightforward reason
for refining that answer is that not all
the many religious practices of human
beings are centered on deities some
focus on spirits or ancestors or even on
impersonal forces with which it's
important for people to align themselves
more importantly though doctrines things
to be believed by the devout aren't
central to all forms of religion for the
moment I'm going to set that concern
aside and consider an obvious refinement
of the incautious proposal religions
invoke something beyond the mundane
physical world some transcendent realm
to invoke a term that's as vague as it
is useful and popular and they offer
doctrines about this transcendent so all
around the world religious people avow
doctrinal statements they declare that
God made a covenant with Abraham or that
the Prophet was visited by an angel who
commanded him to recite the divine
message
or that Jesus rose from the dead part
but only part of secular humanist doubt
consists in the denial that any of these
statements or any of their counterparts
in other religions is true
now you can't understand that denial nor
appreciate its grounds unless you first
think about what the statements are
supposed to mean a familiar distinction
separates literal controls of religious
claims usually found in particular
scriptures from alternative
interpretations that are metaphorical or
allegorical or poetic that division
however is only a crude way of marking
the ends of a continuum at one pole are
reading supposing that an ancient
Mesopotamian pastoralist was once
visited by an imposing old man with a
long white beard in the style of Blake
or that a mechanist state manager had
repeated encounters in the desert with a
large gleaming figure outfitted with
impressive wings or that the son of a
carpenter from Nazareth was completely
dead and later alive again where the
criteria for life and death are those
laid down by medical practice
now perhaps there are Jews and Muslims
and Christians who subscribe to
precisely those interpretations just as
there are so just as there are some
people who think the world was created
in six periods of exactly 24 hours with
all major kinds of plants and animals
found at the very beginning but I think
most people who profess these faiths
probably don't intend anything so
detailed and specific they allow that
ordinary descriptions fall short that
their doctrines contain mysteries many
religions including the three Abrahamic
versions of monotheism supply a rich
body of statements for the faithful to
interpret idealizing we might assign
each religious believer what I'll call a
doctrinal profile fixed by the level of
detail
and specificity with which she reads
each of the doctrinal statements
sometimes she may import all the
everyday implications of the words used
jesus wept
is construed as claiming that a
particular historical figure shed tears
on a particular occasion in other
instances she may retreat from the
commonplace allusions and implications
Muhammad in the Meccan desert had an
extraordinary experience in which he
conceived an outside source as inspiring
him to repeat certain words no angel no
great figure with impressive wings
extreme literalists are those who insist
that all the doctrinal statements
associated with their religion be read
with the maximal amount of specificity
for them the warfare between science and
religion is typically intense for many
others however the idea of any single
doctrinal profile is an idealization
when pressed people feel unsure exactly
how much of the everyday implications
they want to import into their cradle
professions confessing to doctrinal
indefiniteness they resist producing
clear and unambiguous translations of
statements that play a central role in
their lives to unsympathetic Outsiders
this kind of doctrinal indefiniteness or
even the milder practice of retreating
from the everyday implications of the
language used in formulating religious
claims can appear evasive critics who
detect a contradiction within the body
of religious doctrine or between
articles of doctrine and well confirmed
results of inquiry are informed that the
impaired --nt inconsistency is the
product of simplistic reading or worse
that the exact content of the doctrine
resists specification insistence on
providing definite content for doctrinal
statements ignores the long history of
subtle interpretive strategies
reading the scriptures as well as the
more obvious point that the main
religious texts weren't written by
people intending to submit articles to
scientific journals flexibility of
interpretation is nonetheless easily
abused it allows retreat in responsive
to criticism and a compensator II
advanced later in exhortation to an
audience of the faithful how then in
such murky waters can secular humanism
follow any clear current by permitting
many questions to go unanswered but
demanding an answer to one the core of
secularists doubt is skepticism about
anything
transcendent believers may retreat from
committing themselves to all-powerful
creators with long white beards or
gleaming figures with impressive wings
or to the living physical presence of
someone who was previously fully
medically dead
but so long as they interpret their
doctrines as recording episodes that
were connected with something beyond the
physical organic human world secular
humanism doubts the truth of what is
claimed only when the believer can
forthrightly declare that the
resurrection is a metaphor to convey an
important ideal saying perhaps that when
the man we know as Jesus died
permanently
there was no abrogation of normal
physical and organic processes but that
his acceptance of injustice and
agonizing punishment reveals the
wonderful human possibility of
self-sacrifice only then will
secularists conclude that nothing is
left to provoke resistance strategies of
interpretation may vary doctrines may be
allowed to be indefinite but one
question must be addressed does this
doctrine presuppose some claim about
something transcendent so far all I've
tried to do is identify the nature of
secular humanist doubt I'm now going to
turn to the grounds for skepticism
many religions that once pervaded human
societies have surely vanished without
trace
but even when retention is focused on
those that have survived and from the
historical record we find an astounding
variety in religious doctrines
impersonal forces sacred places
ancestors ghosts spirits demons and a
wide diversity of deities have all
figured as supposed manifestations of
the transcendent sometimes religious
cultures are aware of part of the
variety allowing tolerantly that the
divinities of the neighbors are although
inferior fully real sometimes they're
more aggressive ours is the true
religion all the rest is primitive
superstition assuming for the moment
that the doctrines are understood with
relative specificity so that distinct
religions give very different
characterizations of the transcendent an
obvious question arises how is it
possible to make sense of this diversity
of religious doctrine even when
religions make no explicit claim to
being exclusive it strains credulity to
admit all the rival claims as true
nobody thinks the world is so full of
mystic forces sacred places spirits and
divinities that the entire population of
clayman's can be accommodated so long
then as the interpretation of religious
doctrine is sufficiently specific
literal enough to assert the existence
of personal and impersonal beings a
distinction has to be drawn between
those religions that have an
approximately accurate inventory and
those that are utterly mistaken yet the
basis of belief are remarkably similar
across the entire array of religious
traditions including those
condescendingly characterized as
primitive superstitions leaving what are
taken to be religious experiences on one
side for the moment the religious
convictions of men
contemporary believers are formed in
very much the same ways often the
faithful are born into a religious
tradition whose lore they absorb in
early childhood and continue to accept
throughout their lives sometimes when
the surrounding society contains
adherents of a different doctrine
acquaintance with that religion prompts
conversion and a shift of Allegiance
in either case however religious
believers rely on a tradition they take
that tradition to have carefully
preserved insights once vouchsafe to
privileged witnesses in a remote past
because that pattern is so prevalent in
grounding the religious beliefs of the
present it's very hard to declare that
one of the traditions has a special
status or even that a manageable few
have transmitted truth about the
transcendent the beliefs of each
tradition stand on much the same footing
complete symmetry prevails
how can a devout person deeply convinced
of some specific substantive doctrine
say the claim that the world is the
creation of a single personal deity come
to terms with this predicament to face
it clearly is to recognize that if by
some accident of early childhood
he'd been transported to some distant
culture brought up among Aboriginal
Australians say he would now affirm a
radically different set of doctrines
perhaps about the reverberations of the
Dreamtime in the present and he do so
with the same deep conviction and as a
result of the same type of processes
that characterize his actual beliefs
insisting that his reading of the
favoured scriptures is accompanied by
some special feeling a sense of divinity
artists is fruitless a fig leaf covering
for dogmatism his Australian counterpart
would have AO similar feelings aroused
by listening to narratives about the
sacred places although he wouldn't
decorate his own professions with a
Latin tag defenders of specific
religious doctrines can
this point rightly object that the deck
has been stacked against them through
the deliberate neglect of an important
part of the basis for belief to wit the
religious experiences believers
sometimes have uncontroversially
throughout history people have reported
the episodes in which they've taken
themselves to gain access to the
transcendent although how frequently
such episodes occur is hard to assess
since the available statistics show wild
variation in different years religious
experiences occur in all cultures and
are invariably described using the
categories either of a religion to which
the subject already adheres or of a
religion with which she's familiar
once again symmetry prevails moreover
cultures are typically sensitive to the
possibility that those who report
religious experiences have been deceived
even that they've been seduced into
wickedness and they introduce special
procedures for validating claims to
encounter the transcendent requiring
that the messages allegedly delivered
conform to the orthodoxy handed down
across the generations as for example in
the medieval certification of anchorites
instead of serving as an independent
source of justification for religious
doctrine religious experience is thus
parasitic on the deliverances of
tradition not all of the full array of
specific doctrines about the
transcendent can be accepted as true
indeed the overwhelming majority of them
must be regarded as thoroughly false
nevertheless the processes through which
those doctrines have come to be adopted
are all of the same general type and
there's no basis for distinguishing the
wheat from the chaff under these
circumstances secular humanists conclude
that we should deny all of them that
conclusion is reinforced by two
centuries of careful investigation of
religious traditions and their evolution
scholars have traced the ways in which
the scriptural canon has been assembled
showing how incompatible conceptions of
what are supposedly the same transcend
phenomena and of the same historical
events have been fused presumably
in an effort to incorporate distinctive
ideas favored by different groups so
that they can share a religious
perspective scholars have demonstrated
the ways in which doctrine has been
shifted to respond to the felt needs or
aspirations of potential converts and
how its adapted to the political
pressures of the moment marks a con
torta de count of the role of the Jews
in demanding that Jesus be subjected to
a Roman punishment is a case in point a
fiction that has caused extraordinary
harm but that surely eased the passage
of early Christianity in a Rome
dominated world sociologists have
studied how contemporary religions
accommodate the psychological needs of
those they hope to recruit and how the
accommodations modify the Orthodox
interpretations of religious claims and
the emphasis placed on particular tax
the megachurches of the wealthy suburbs
don't usually urge the centrality to
Christianity of the Sermon on the Mount
although the psychological study of
religious experience is handicapped by
recent sensitivities about the
legitimacy of controlled experiments
it's no longer considered acceptable to
administer psychotropic drugs to
unwitting subjects in the hope of
identifying an increased frequency in
reports of encounters with the
transcendent the available evidence
amply supports the conclusion that
religious experiences are more likely to
happen to people who are psychologically
disturbed or are who and/or who are
under the influence of substances
typically viewed as interfering with
clear and reliable perception the moral
of all this is that the roots to
contemporary acceptance of religious
doctrines are not merely of the same
generic type across societies and
cultures but the historical genesis of
belief is pervaded if not entirely
dominated by processes of kinds quite
unlikely to yield correct beliefs
shaping ideas about the transcend
and to evade political pressures or to
accommodate the wishes of hoped for
converts isn't a reliable means of
generating true doctrines or even of
better approximating the truth simply
absorbing the reports of a religious
experience provided by all and sundry
would in fact doctrine with all manner
of delusions which is why successful
traditions have insisted on conformity
to orthodoxy and why many subjects of
religious experience
the Prophet prominent among them have
worried about the genuineness of their
voices and their visions most specific
religious doctrines must be false and
since all emerge from the same generic
style of historic development it follows
that generating belief in that way isn't
reliable two centuries worth of studies
literary historical sociological
political and anthropological add an
explanation of the unreliability by
doing so they deepened the secular
humanist case for doubt now what I've
said faces obvious rejoinders and it
needs qualification the first and most
natural perhaps is that the act is the
accusation of distorting the religious
perspective by emphasizing knowledge and
ignoring faith what exactly is being
shown a critic might ask merely that
specific religious doctrines are not
held as items of knowledge or perhaps
more precisely not held as the kind of
knowledge that requires reliable ways of
generating and sustaining belief
thoughtful religious people should have
been ready to concede as much from the
beginning they should have insisted that
religious doctrines are held on the
basis of faith and if it's apt to see
them also as knowledge its knowledge of
a distinctive sort that's the critic yet
the ground on which he invites us to
tread is slippery
we should go slowly first is their
religious knowledge apparently it's
claimed by some prominent religious
traditions in one of handle settings
soprano sings gloriously of her
knowledge of the living Redeemer if that
knowledge is of some special type an
explanation is needed to show the
kinship with the everyday conception
otherwise talk of knowledge would just
be a misleading pun more importantly the
notion of faith is many-sided faith can
be constituted by trust in a person or
in some manifestation of the
transcendent it could consist in
commitment to an ideal or to living in a
particular way if however the issue
concerns the acceptance of specific
religious doctrines the most
straightforward sense involves a
contrast with belief on the basis of
evidence in the uncharitable qyp faith
is when you believe and you know it
ain't so on a slightly more sympathetic
reading faith is belief that outruns the
evidence available to the believer
according to some religious people even
if religious doctrines are held without
compelling evidence such belief is
legitimate what standard of legitimacy
is at issue here not an epistemic one we
aren't dealing with reasonableness in
human sense when he declares that
reasonable people proportioned their
beliefs to the evidence to confute
religious faith by declaring that
legitimate beliefs are simply defined as
those based on the available evidence
would be silly a glorious victory only
for humpty-dumpty fans of faith hope to
offer a different view
they hope to set human practices of
forming belief within a broader context
one in which many different types of
values come into play and they regard a
leap beyond the evidence as permissible
in light of the entire spectrum of those
values or at least of the most important
ones and so the legitimacy at stake is
ethical William James is delicious or
farter Hiedler wk Clifford denied any
such legitimacy he argued that it is
wrong always everywhere and for anyone
to believe anything on the basis of
insufficient evidence
and he thereby provoked James to write
what is probably the most influential
article ever written by any American
philosopher Clifford defended his
sweeping generalization by considering
scenarios in which believing beyond the
evidence leads to actions causing great
harm or the risk of such harm the heart
of James's reply identifies different
possibilities cases in which abstaining
from belief would forfeit valuable
consequences for the believer and in
which the impact on the welfare of
others can be assumed to be negligible
the solitary Mountaineer wills himself
into believing that a difficult leap
will succeed the suitor who courts his
beloved with unwarranted confidence
increases his personal chances of
success
neither inflicts damage on anyone else
secularists can concede the validity of
these examples and yet deny the ethical
permissibility of holding religious
doctrines by a leap of faith
precisely because religious commitments
typically pervade the lives of the
devout they aren't insulated from
actions actions with serious
consequences for others to believe in
earnest is typically a spur to doing
something else to proselytizing even to
coercion punishment and campaigns to
eradicate the party of evil only if the
tie between belief and action were
completely cut or if it were firmly
subordinated to ethical values could the
adoption of specific doctrine on the
basis of faith be legitimate in the
first case what the believer declares in
her heart would never be expressed in
her conduct leaving a faith so
attenuated as to be scarcely worthy of
the name in the second which is the
important one I think the primarily
religious commitment is to orient life
by recognizing important values and
belief in doctrine figures only as a
means to ethical ends faith becomes
ethically legitimate because it's
focused from the beginning on the
ethical
viewing faith as a commitment to the
most fundamental ethical ideals is the
most direct way of responding to
Clifford's critique but it's quite at
odds with one of the most celebrated our
ideas about faith Kierkegaard's
provocative attempt to justify religious
faith Abraham the knight of faith is
prepared to sacrifice his son Isaac to
fulfill a divine command he's fully
aware of his ethical obligation to
protect the boy
he loves Isaac deeply and he recognizes
that the sacrifice will nullify God's
promise to him that his descendants will
cover the earth not only does he believe
on insufficient evidence but he does so
knowing that the combination of his
convictions is paradoxical he believes
in virtue of the absurd while admitting
that he doesn't understand Abraham
Kierkegaard admires him precisely
because of his willingness to suspend
the ethical and to honor the absolute
duty to God now if you're tempted to
discern some overriding value in
Abraham's devotion to the deity then you
should reflect on the fact that what
he's prepared to do would deprive his
son of any similar opportunity to do the
same thing the nobility of being the
knight of faith is purchased by denying
that opportunity to Isaac Abraham stands
at the end of a continuum of those who
are ready to do profoundly inhumane
things in the name of religious faith a
continuum whose other milder pole is
occupied by the irresponsible believers
who so troubled clifford giving a
general license to commitments to
religious doctrines that outrun the
evidence allows the members of this
diverse array of human cultures and
societies to act on the basis of
whatever interpretation they give to
whatever sayings or texts they choose to
permit their inspiration to be mine camp
or the 120
days of sodom and that's to tolerate
fanaticism in any or all of its guises
unless the application of doctrine is
always subordinated to a commitment to
ethical values unless there's no
suspension of the ethical the invocation
of faith can't legitimize acceptance of
religious doctrine so secular humanism
denies specific doctrines about the
transcendent the conflicts among them
and the unreliability of the processes
that have generated them make it
virtually certain that they're one and
all false
nor can adherents to such doctrines be
condoned by supposing that believers
exercise an ethically permissible
expression of faith yet secularists
needn't categorically deny the existence
of the transcendent they ought to be
mindful of the history of inquiries into
the natural world scientists have often
been confident that major features of
nature have been finally determined only
to learn that radical revision is in
order on the basis of what we now take
ourselves to know there's good evidence
of skepticism not only about all extant
specific doctrines about the
transcendent but about the reality of
the transcendent in any form nor does
that assessment change under the broader
purview if we imagine rigorous
applications of currently approved
methods for justifying belief from where
we now stand acceptance of anything
transcendent is a wild leap belief is
surely speculative conjecture
nevertheless the history of human
knowledge has been marked by recurrent
surprises the world has often turned out
to be richer and stranger than it
previously been suspected secularists
can't rule out the possibility that
someday the future march of rigorous
inquiry will disclose an aspect of
reality
apparently dimly prefigured in some
religious doctrines inspiring the
retrospective judgment so that's what
the world's religions were trying to
gesture at all along
attempts to envisage the details of the
discovery defeat the imagination
it's hardly unreasonable to attribute
low probability to the scenario yet the
bare possibility should be admitted
history suggests that when ancient ideas
are resurrected the anticipations
are retrospectively recognized as vague
and embryonic by analogy if some notion
of a transcendent realm is rehabilitated
we can expect it to exceed the
conceptual grasp of its earlier
champions barring extraordinary luck
specific religious doctrines will be
revealed as thoroughly erroneous and
indeed as framed an entirely inadequate
language even if the day of discovery
dawns it's overwhelmingly unlikely to
vindicate the Dreamtime or the
transmigration of souls the Hindu
Pantheon or the Trinity even the bare
thought of a divine creator or of a mind
behind the universe all the categories
religions have deployed are almost
certainly inadequate to their intended
task pursuit of doubt leads secular
humanism to a position rarely made
explicit agnostic atheism to give it an
unattractive name the agnostic part of
the view consists in allowing that while
there is no basis for endorsing the
transcendent the bare possibility of
some future justified acceptance of it
can't be eliminated with respect to the
substantive doctrines of the world's
religions agnostic theists are less
accommodating there are excellent
grounds for supposing all such doctrines
to be thoroughly false so much I take to
be beyond doubt now to be more
conciliatory the most prominent
contemporary critiques of religion
prompt many believers to reply that they
don't touch the real faith the form of
devotion espoused by the most thoughtful
and sensitive inherent adherents critics
are accused of oversimplifying of
substituting crude caricatures for
complex commitments of assimilating all
- fundamentalism the accusations have
some merit in the prominent contemporary
forms of atheism presuppose that
religious doctrines must be read with
considerable specificity yet to dismiss
atheist critiques as substituting
caricatures for finally shaded portraits
overlooks an obvious fact however subtle
the religious conceptions of those who
inhabit divinity schools or faculties of
religion of those who write books or
book reviews about religious questions
many believers would acquiesce in the
interpretive approaches assumed by the
critics the devout often read religious
doctrines just as the atheists do indeed
the fast growing fastest growing
religions in many parts of the world are
those insisting on substantive doctrines
construed with considerable specificity
literalist religions the real faith may
be untouched by contemporary broadsides
it may have been articulated and
defended for centuries by the most
intelligent and subtle religious
thinkers but it's hardly the form of
religion that is most vital and
sometimes most violent in the modern
world my skeptical argument to doesn't
target all forms of religion it's been
marked by places where I've made
assumptions places where alternative
conceptions of religion might be
developed
assuming first that religions are
centered on doctrines second that
doctrines are read by importing the
specific implications of the words used
to formulate them and third that faith
is not primarily viewed as a commitment
to ethical values and ideals my
secularist argument generates its
agnostic atheist conclusion but when you
suspend those assumptions it's possible
to recognize an alternative conception
of religion and alternative versions of
major world religions that evade the
reasoning moreover this rival conception
allows an elaboration of religious
challenges
ooh secular humanism it does enables
important issues to be joined to
identify this alternative perspective
I'm going to begin from a possibility I
glossed over in presenting the
secularist argument sometimes a
challenge to select from an array of
conflicting options can be met by
seeking an approach that restricts
itself to their shared features the
symmetry that prevails across religious
doctrines might be accommodated by
affirming a common core instead of
making an arbitrary and dogmatic
assertion that the substantive doctrines
of some specific tradition are correct
the religious believer contends that all
the world's religions share an insight
their least common denominator when the
focus is on religions as bodies of
doctrine and when the language of
doctrinal formulations is understood by
importing many of the everyday
implications of the words an attempt to
evade the symmetry argument can
reasonably be ignored for the diversity
of conceptions of the transcendent dooms
the alleged
doucoure doctrine to vacuity gods and
spirits ancestors and mystic forces and
sacred places lack enough shared
features unless we present the least
common denominator in explicitly
normative terms the transcendent we
might say which defies detailed human
description is worthy of special
emotional attitudes of reverence of or
perhaps of devotion so understood the
world's religions can be appreciated as
apprehending an aspect of reality the
transcendent that exceeds any human
ability to describe except in language
that is normative or metaphorical or
allegorical or poetic all doctrinal
statements are literally false for that
is the way of figures of speech but
literal truth isn't and never was the
issue
the crucial point concerns the capatch
city of metaphors myths and stories to
orient the lives of the faithful in
valuable ways pose William James is
insistent question and asked if the
fruits for life are good raising that
question across the spectrum of the
world's religions and through their
historical development might elicit
judgments about the progress or
backsliding of particular religions it
might assess some religious traditions
as superior to others it might give
priority for example to those that
developed in the so called axial age
nonetheless even if complete symmetry
prevailed that would be no tragedy but
it would simply register an odd quirk of
history the ability of all human
cultures to generate equally effective
metaphors for coping with a significant
but literally indescribable aspect of
reality
now secular humanism acknowledges the
bare possibility of the transcendent but
regards the present insertion of its
existence as entirely unwarranted a
religious perspective need not quarrel
with that assessment the assessment of
the transcendent and of particular
stories and images as gestures toward it
may be based on faith leaping beyond the
evidence is ethically suspect except
when the product of faith is a
commitment to the ethical itself a
viable religious perspective one that
can evade the strictures of my
secularist argument can identify the
transcendent with the source of virtues
ideals and duties of values in the
broadest and deepest sense at the core
of religion then is not a body of
doctrine descriptions of the
transcendent but a commitment to what
James calls the eternal things external
and independent of the believer indeed
of all human beings the doctrines of the
favored religion are then seen as
metaphors stories apt for conveying the
most fundamental values and for guiding
the devout towards realizing them so
understood
religion escapes the secularist argument
by diverging from some assumptions on
which that argument depends an obvious
worry is that success is only achieved
through so attenuating the notion of
religion that the resultant perspective
is no longer worthy of the name the
heart of the religious attitude is faith
understood as a commitment to an
objective order of values a commitment
shared among many religious traditions
although perhaps not by those that have
failed to take crucial progressive steps
faith is further articulated as a
commitment to particular values and
perhaps to a particular ordering of
values and at that stage there might be
divergence and conflict among particular
among different religions so far however
nothing distinguishes this was religious
perspective from ventures in secular
philosophy that maintain the existence
of objective values and view the world's
cultures as advancing different often
incompatible conceptions of the
independent ethical order so have I
saved religion only by collapsing it
into realism about values a religious
attitude can distinguish itself from
secular acceptance of an independent
ethical order in several different ways
first it adopts a picture of a two-tier
universe beyond the physical organic
human realm is a higher level one in
which the grounds of value are located
the worth of human lives and the ethical
status of human deeds are measured not
by the relations that prevail within the
physical organic human domain the lower
level but through their relation to the
transcendent the higher tier in this
spirit Kierkegaard's claims about the
suspension of the ethical can be
reinterpreted less literally and more
sympathetically by envisaging the
possibility that the mundane ethics of
human relations is both superseded and
deepened by a higher order of ethical
life grounded in the transcendent out of
this picture comes a first challenge to
secular humanism can secularists really
provide a satisfactory account
of values or do their proposals generate
inferior surrogates that diminish the
worth of which human lives are capable a
second way of differentiating the
religious life from secular commitments
to an independent order of values
results from embedding the commitment to
the transcendent within an array of
traditional religious practices Buddhism
Hinduism Judaism Christianity and Islam
can all be developed so as to abandon
the literal truth of tales about the
transcendent while retaining the
ceremonies rituals community structures
shared ethical endeavors and even the
creedal professions of their more
literalist relations sometimes those for
whom doctrinal statements are
metaphorical through and through may
mingle peacefully with their cousins
whose declarations make more substantive
claims about the transcendent other
people inspired by elements of different
religions may integrate parts of
disparate traditions in a novel eclectic
synthesis yet others like Emerson may
start explicitly from an abstract notion
of the transcendent and consider the
design of substitutes for the rites and
community structures of neighboring
religious life distinctive parts of
antecedent religious practice are thus
preserved modified recombined or
refashioned from scratch always subject
to the basic condition that when
doctrinal statements are pondered or
uttered they are interpreted
figuratively
once again the distinction between
religious life and the secularists
commitment to values presents a
challenge for secularists secular
humanism these features of religious
life are essential if people are to cope
with their mortality and with the
potential meaninglessness of their lives
the third difference between the
religious attitude and that of the
secular believer in an objective order
of values follows James in supposing
particular types of emotion to pervade
the attitude to the transcendent
acceptance of a higher realm that serves
as the source of values
accompanied by solemnity and/or a humble
willingness to subordinate and redirect
the impulses of the self and yet a
joyful acquiescence in that discipline
what the stoic must labor to accept is
welcomed gladly so the religious life
unfolds with confidence and hope seeing
the existence of a higher tier of
reality as a promise
that values can be sought and at least
partially achieved from this approach to
distinguishing the religious attitude
emerges a third challenge for secular
humanism when human lives are bereft of
all these important emotions toward the
transcendent they are diminished perhaps
through the loss of dimensions of
experience available to the believer
perhaps through the inadequacy of any
purely secular discipline to govern the
darker impulses that belong
intrinsically to human nature so I've
tried to present a version of religion
which I'm going to call purified
religion that escapes the main argument
for secularism purified religion I think
captures major features of the positions
defended by those people who
characterized the manifestos of
contemporary atheists as crude
caricatures on some occasions champions
of purified religion and secular
humanists may identify one another as
allies because both acknowledge the
falsehood of substantive doctrines
they're likely to band together against
people who insist that religion requires
belief in specific claims about the
transcendent weather the insistent are
advocates for particular doctrines or
whether their critics who take the end
of literal doctrine to be the death of
religion secular humanists may well
admire the appreciation of simple of
symmetry among religious traditions
hoping that the consequent resolve to
view many of the world's religions as
attempting metaphorical evocations of
the same transcendent reality is an
important step toward ending religious
conflict finally since secular humanism
is a positive perspective one concerned
with the value of human life
it's in a thoroughly natural world it
appreciates a focus on the right
questions and even the presentation of
important challenges in the end however
peaceful coexistence must give way to
renewed argument that debate
specifically engagement with the three
main challenges that I've just noted
will be the substance of my next three
lectures thank you
thank you very much we do have time for
questions there are a couple of rules
and there were people who resist every
year these rules if you have a question
you have to come to the microphone this
is not because we won't be able to hear
you so don't set your seat and say I can
ask from here and make myself heard
we're recording this that's why you have
to come to the microphone so just please
make your way up to either microphone on
either side if you have questions you'd
like to ask
hi my name is Tom Platt I have it had
trouble keeping up with you would you
explain what you meant by symmetry sure
so what I mean by symmetry here is that
the the grounds of the beliefs in
various different substantive doctrines
are all of the same generic type so if
you imagine somebody who is brought up
in Australia and in an Aboriginal group
and comes to believe in the dream time
and its reverberations in the present
and we imagine somebody else who's
brought up say in a Christian community
in the United States and we look at the
the the processes that stand behind
their beliefs what explains why they why
they come to have the beliefs that they
do in both cases it's pretty much the
same thing allegedly back in the past
there were these these these special
experiences these special encounters
which were then transmitted to people
and there's a long tradition which is
preserved that and that now delivers it
to the contemporary believer that's the
simplest way to get out what's
symmetrical about this so the Christian
if transported to the Aboriginal
situation would believe in much the same
kind of way in the Dreamtime okay does
that help
well what I came to at the end was an
attempt to come to terms of this
symmetry argument so what I wanted to
use the symmetry argument for was to
cast extreme doubt on the idea that any
of these specific substantive doctrines
say that there is only one God and this
God comes in three persons or the
doctrine that there was once a dream
time and that this dream time has
reverberated throughout the creation in
various sacred places those are two
different doctrines about the
transcendent I want to say that the
symmetry of the grounds on which those
things are believed make us rightly
extremely skeptical about those
propositions on the other hand my
version of purified religion attempted
to get as it were underneath the
symmetry and say look there's something
out there that all of these different
religious traditions would their expense
stories they're different metaphors are
getting at and they gesture to it in in
inadequate ways so the thought of behind
in purified religion is that we couldn't
take any of these specific doctrines
literally none of them at all even the
minimal doctrine that there is a single
creator of the universe or a mind behind
it all all of that strictly speaking is
false and yet there's something out
there to which religions as a whole are
responding and which they express in
their different individual inadequate
ways when whether they're inadequate for
the purposes of description on the other
hand those waves may be thoroughly
adequate and useful for the purposes of
guiding the adherents of religion
towards appreciating understanding and
trying to realize the right kinds of
values that's the vision of purified
religion that I tried to develop at the
end so the argument came in various bits
I started off by focusing as atheists
typically do on specific
bits of substantive doctrine and in
trying to give what I think is the most
compelling reason for thinking that all
of the substantive doctrines of all of
the major world religions with their
importation of ordinary ideas about life
and death and so forth but all of those
strictly speaking of false I then said
we can get beyond this by understanding
the structure of the argument that leads
to that conclusion and seeing the places
at which assumptions are made and we can
generate out of that a form of religion
that escapes the criticism I called it
purified religion and that's the sort of
religion that you just alluded to it's
the it's the idea of this encompassing
and human response to something
important but it must be committed
through it what I've tried to do is
clarify that and see that it must be
committed through and through to the
idea of religious specific religious
doctrines as being figurative and
metaphorical thank you for identifying
yourself that actually reminded me that
I didn't tell you the second rule which
is we please identify yourself when you
ask a question thank you for doing that
hi my name is John Peter thank you for
the very engaging lecture I was a bit
and obviously you're pressed for time
intellectual like this but unsatisfied
with the initial argument for scepticism
which was a kind and just register to
complaints and see if maybe you can
address them the first is it seemed like
the method that you pointed to is being
unreliable was very coarse-grained and
that it would be much more complicated
and maybe the argument to fall apart if
it was much more of a fine-grained
understanding in the method for instance
it's not just that we of course most
people do follow the face of their
community or their parents maybe there's
a religious experience involved but some
traditions may supplement their belief
forming process with the robust natural
may not of course within those that do
there may be very different types of
natural theology so much you may be more
friendly to kind of philosophy you do in
some which you may not be friendly to so
there's a lot of fine grained
distinctions there and once you get
fine-grained enough you know you might
find that hey there's you no longer have
this kind of diversity argument to go
with but the second question is just
that this kind of worry is so broad and
it can lead to skepticism so
wide-ranging outside of the domain of
religion I do agree that it's worse and
religion than in other areas but just
take for one example of the belief
polarization literature says hey people
come in they read the same articles and
the death penalty and they leave being
more polarized and more extreme in their
views so that's a a worrying
unreliability claim which should I think
reduce our confidence but the natural
response to that is to say well let's
not form our beliefs in the way that
everyone else does let's focus on a
different kind of method look to those
who we think are particularly epistemic
lis epistemic exemplary and that would
just lead to a much more complicated I
think picture in terms it seemed like a
kind of broad brush quick dismissal the
transcendent those are very good
questions and they deserve really
detailed and elaborated answers so well
with respect to the first question
here's the challenge so you look at all
of these you look at all of these
traditions from a very broad brush
perspective and say all they all do
things in much the same way that's like
looking at people forming their beliefs
and saying well people use their eyes
and their memories and they do a bit of
thinking but of course we can make finer
distinctions among people's beliefs some
people think better than others some
people see better than others some
people remember better than others and
so when you look more closely you can
see grounds on which you can actually
break the symmetry and now connecting
this with the second part of the
challenge this sort of symmetry argument
is sometimes used across factual beliefs
or with respect to human cultures by
people who are sort of fans of cultural
relativism and they say well look
yes you know you take all this stuff
that's given to you by Western science
very seriously about in different
cultures they have different views and
if you look at the ways in which views
are generated that's all pretty much the
same way and the restraint response to
that is just the response that you
suggested for the religious cases which
is look more closely look more closely
at the kinds of processes that are going
on here look at the ways in which
different cultures and different groups
arrive at your beliefs at their beliefs
and you'll find ways of breaking the
symbols of symmetry that's completely
seems to me completely correct what I
want to to do however is to assert that
when you look more closely at the
religious case it actually doesn't get
any better that if you look at the ways
in which religions modify and
accommodate and change their traditions
the ways in which religious doctrine
evolves you can see that this is
pervaded by forms of belief revision
that are very unreliable and that was
really the point of my appeal to that
what I think of as a great enlightenment
tradition that begins about two
centuries ago with looking at critical
studies of religion of very many kinds
anthropological psychological
sociological historical and literary and
it seems to me that those actually do
show that the situation with respect to
religious belief is not only a bit worse
than it is in other domains but a lot
worse now the quays the case of values
to which you alluded is I think a
particularly interesting one and and
actually quite a troubling one and that
is that so I think I can fight a very
clearly for a more a marked difference
between the scientific case say where I
think when one looks more closely the
symmetry can be broken and the religious
case will and when one looks more
closely the symmetry seems to be if
anything deepened by by the closer
looking but the case of values is really
hard and I want to say more about that
on on Thursday and maybe your question
will come back with renewed vengeance at
that point I want to try to assimilate
actually the values case more to the
scientific case and to cut it off from
from the religious case I think that
just to give you a foretaste
I think that we are still struggling to
and this is a very dewy end point do we
thought that something remarkable had
happened in the 17th century that people
had then discovered a method that could
be used for finding things out about the
physical world about nature and that the
the imperative task for philosophy in
the early 20th century and I think you
would say in the early 21st century too
was to do the same sort of thing with
respect to the human and the the moral
sciences I think that's absolutely right
I think we're still struggling towards a
method for for finding out and reaching
consensus on matters of values and
breaking the simple the symmetry here
but it's still a work in progress and I
will be talking about that on Thursday
but thank you those are excellent
questions and I intend in the written
version to say much more about that as
as you rightly suggested